هنا في جوهانسبرج ، كانت هناك مشاهد
من الفوضى طوال اليوم ، حيث يحاول رجال الإطفاء إطفاء
متجر أضرمت فيه النيران في هذه
الاحتجاجات والنهب في
جميع أنحاء البلاد على وجه التحديد في
هذه المقاطعة وفي
مقاطعة كويزيناتل ، كان هناك
نهب
للشرطة ولم يكن لها تأثير يذكر على
إيقافه  الناس من القيام بذلك
في المستقبل إذا تمكنا من الدفع ، فهذا في الغالب عبارة عن
أمن خاص ، وبعضهم بأسلحة نارية حية
كنا في مركز تجاري جنوب المدينة
حيث كانت مجرد مشاهد كاملة من الفوضى
ثلاثة أو أربعة من رجال الشرطة يحاولون الحفاظ على
الخط بالفعل.
تم نهب المركز التجاري هناك شعور بأن هذا
العمل الاحتجاجي هو الأسوأ الذي شهدته جنوب
إفريقيا لسنوات عديدة وهذا
النهب
يخرج عن السيطرة تمامًا ، قالوا
إن الجيش سينتشر
في الشوارع
التي بدأها بسبب الرئيس جاكوب
زوما السابق  يتم وضع الرئيس في
السجن بتهمة الازدراء
ولكن يبدو بعد ذلك أنه ذهب إلى أبعد من
ذلك الأشخاص الذين يستغلون
الفوضى
في هذا البلد وينهبون  في العديد من
مراكز التسوق والمحلات التجارية
أه غالبًا بالقرب من المناطق الأفقر في
كوازولو ناتال
وهذه هي المشاهد هنا
يحاول الأمن الخاص
وقف النهب ولكن حتى الآن
يحققون نجاحًا محدودًا
لديفيد
ماكنزي سي إن جوهانسبرج